Cái công tức nè các mùa con kết thương đất biểu là một trên đêm thì bình thửo một trên đa bình công với các bình ché đình của hóa.
Thì trong lỗi các cái tát chí này.
Lâu tiên là hát thì là khoảng cách từ điểm em đến mặt khoảng bây giờ sê.
M普 đứng lên tục, kẹm tính là bằng át bằng hay căn bà.
Ha, thì là khoảng cách từ đi, thì nó xây thì bằng ôi giống.
Bằng đều bằng các bác trên 2 thì bằng hay căn bà.
Bên hông thời ká để kẹm từ nước em thì xô.
Cái mở kẹm đi thử ní của điên,
And đi hết trên đều thì bằng bố phần bà.
Đó và kìa mắp vào tụng thức.
Cái này xong rồi.
Đôi, ok.
Dất trưởng về lỗi nước quá.
Tìa chí của chúng ta sẽ là xong kinh bà.
Chí nắm.
Dất hay.
Và giá chí này xong xí đã hạt cũng tạm.